where would we put 13 over 5 on this
number line so first let's make sure
what these slashes represent on the
number line so when i have i'm starting
at zero one slash two slash three
slashes and they're marking this is
three so each slash must be one so this
must be one and this must be two and it
all works out one two and three now for
the way my brain works i like to write
this 13 over five as a mixed number so
it lets me know how far well up to what
number should i go to and then how far
past that number should i go so let's
write this as this improper fraction is
a mixed number and the easiest way to do
that is divide 5 into 13.
so let me write this 5 goes into 13
13 fifths is the same thing as 13
divided by 5 as 13 divided by 5 or 5
divided into 13.
5 goes into 13 2 times 2 times 5 is 10
and our remainder is going to be three
so 13 over five is the same thing is the
exact same thing as
two
as two and three over five
two and three over five
two and three
over
five
and so now we're ready to plot it if we
keep increasing this is one this gets us
to two but now we have to go another
three-fifths and so let me mark off the
fifths over here so this is one-fifth
two-fifth three-fifths four-fifths and
then five-fifths will get us to the next
whole number which is three so three of
these fifths so one two three puts us
right over there that is 13
13 over five we went one two and then we
looked at the fifths we went one two
three fifths two and three fifths or
thirteen over fifths thirteen over five